[Music]
hello and welcome to the media
responsibility and a good story debate
i'm ariane seek heart and we look to
journalists in the media to challenge
the authority and uncover failure as
well of courses to entertain us but in
the face of a national and now currently
a global crisis some people have argued
that the media focus on challenging
government hyping drama and focusing on
negative stories is irresponsible so
should the media of lloyd creating fear
and panic in a population and does it
have a duty to put threat into context
or should journalism just always be
driven by the bigger story but bad news
usually sells a great deal better than
good news
well we've got to practitioners
journalistic practitioners here today
and a politician all of whom i think
will be fascinating on this subject
David good heart is journalists and
cultural commentator he's the founder
and former editor of Prospect magazine
and the author of a road to somewhere
Nick Robinson's worked at the BBC for
over thirty years including as political
editor for ten of those and he's now of
course one of the presenters of BBC
Radio 4's Today programme and just
Phillips is Labour MP for Birmingham
Yardley she's a big campaigner for
women's issues and she stood in the most
recent labor leadership election so
should the media avoid creating fear and
panic even at the risk of sugaring the
truth thing to start with Jess I mean I
think that at the beginning of the
coronavirus crisis there was a real risk
and we were all incredibly aware of
trying to not cause panic whether that
was from the things that we said in
Parliament or the things that were being
written about and there was a sort of an
idea of desiring trust in the government
because trust in the government really
mattered at the beginning of the crisis
above all almost anything but the only
thing I think that needs to happen the
only thing that is above that is truth
and I actually don't think that you
should ever try and sugar the truth for
the sake of you know if you're gonna
cause absolute mass hysteria that is
something that has to be managed if
you're a politician and in fact you know
the media they're not irresponsible they
have ethics around this issue but the
truth which it seems is very very hard
to get to quite a lot of the time and
certainly has felt like that during this
crisis the truth above anything else I
think actually eases panicked if you
feel like you are being informed of
things whether they are good or bad I
think that people are much less likely
to panic you start to panic when you
feel people are lying to you and so I
don't think that I think that the the
media have a responsibility to cover
what is the truth it's when they lie for
the sake of not necessarily lie but spin
a story for the sake of other things
whether that's reputation of their
favored actor in in a particular
instance or where where you stick to the
truth as the simplest golden thread I
think you're on the right side Nick
Roberson
well my starting point is always that it
is a job of journalists to think through
the consequences of what they were and I
deliberately do that as boldly as I can
I don't it's our job it's our job to try
to get to the truth to try and explain s
to try and analyze to try and hold
people to account but not to go and if
we do that what they're now the reason I
see use the word journalists Marianne
rather the media is of me to bring a
concept the BBC is a national
broadcaster you have to pay a compulsory
levy in order to watch it so yes the BBC
has some responsibility is to the
country whether it is getting us to
exercise in lockdown making sure we can
get to culture raising our spirits as
all sorts of things the BBC has a
responsibility
morally but that's the BBC not the news
the muse is in a different category and
I do think the news is in a different
category and broadcast news is in a
different category from print and what's
online because we're regulated we're
obliged by law to try at least to be
impartial to be fair to be objective and
so on but overall I think we've always
got to be incredibly careful of those
people who tell us what our
responsibility is because usually it's
politicians who want to conflate their
own interests with the national interest
they usually say that really we're at
war you've seen Boris Johnson who's
Winston Churchill's biographer do this
again and again and we're all with the
virus well no we're not actually a war
with a virus that it blame them for
using the rhetoric but the reason he
does it is said that it supports us then
can then say well you're being disloyal
you're being treacherous almost as if
the virus suddenly has intelligent
services who are listening in to the
delay program when somebody's critical
what the government's doing the virus go
haha that's what we're gonna do that
virus isn't my bad
it's also not clear even the following
the scientific advice nice for me is the
right thing to do there's lots of
different scientific advice that people
you think we've wildly overreacted in
terms of the lockdown and that lots of
people will die as a result of poverty
as a result of domestic abuse
as a result of other conditions not
treated so there isn't even objectively
one way of determining what does cause
fear that is dangerous and what doesn't
cause fear so he tells you that the
media should behave more responsibly and
more morally they usually in favor of
you not doing your job okay david guetta
yeah I mean I I don't think either the
politicians all the media have have
adapted very well to these peculiar
circumstances I mean the politicians
have not been very good at sort of
communicating the balance of risk
they're not being as it were kind of you
know revealing their workings as much as
they should have done I think we will
have all wanted them to do
when I say politicians also I mean the
government they've been very defensive
you know they haven't I mean I think
there's a huge amount to be said for
kind of admitting failures but at the
same time the media too has been it's
been sort of typically adversarial I
mean I you know obviously they should
point out when things are failing but
exactly why they are failing is a very
complicated question usually and there's
been that sort of slightly kinda nanny
state assumption somehow have the kind
of omniscience of government and
therefore that anything that goes wrong
must be the fault of government I mean
you've seen this time after time after
time on the care home question and I
mean when talking about the me
government I obviously I haven't and
none of us have been watching or reading
everything I mean I my my main criticism
of the news is I have been watching
quite a lot of BBC news at 6 and 10 and
I have been really quite shocked by what
has been coming at this of my TV now
that may well be because I I'm not used
to watching it but my god it is it is it
tabloid it is in crowd coverage is so
over emotional I think where I think the
whole country is having us all certainly
the the the coverage is all is sort of
almost a sort of second Diana moment
hugely more emotional that I've been
watching two equivalent TV news programs
in France and Germany they are miles
miles better they are much less focused
on the death cult I mean I mean half the
program often on BBC sorry I mean off
the program is about death and is about
people you know weeping into the camera
and saying my granny is not a statistic
I mean we kind of know that and it's at
you know we know there's a lot of
tragedy around but we want context we
want explanation and we're getting
masses of emotion and I think it's and
it's I think it's dispiriting I know
millions of people who just stop
watching the main news programs because
it's because it's so dispiriting
and I mean I you know I understand you
know the BBC's got to try and attract
youth and and all of that but it's sort
of its straining I mean I mean and this
doesn't apply them and this is TV it
doesn't apply to I'm gonna listen to a
bit of p.m. and world that one I haven't
I have admit I'm not a great listener to
this a day program and you know even rod
little a great BBC skeptic was praising
world at one and p.m. in the Sunday
Times today so I yeah I mean I I do
think there is a real problem with with
the coverage it's not so much that they
relentlessly attacked the government
although they do I mean I don't mind
them doing that if they just kind of
doing it intelligently but it's sort of
you know they just week day after day
they could have repeat the same
accusations from the from the care home
people they never seem to kind of
investigate and so what's happened to
this 3.2 billion pounds at the
government you know I mean what can't we
follow the money and find out you know
why is it why is it not getting you know
let's investigate a bit let's find out
what you know is it are we too
centralized not centralized enough what
are the kind of institutional blockages
it's so unintelligent I think you need
Nick Toth to respond to all this I know
you only you can't represent the whole
of the BBC as I say they may not apply
it may not apply to the today program
which I haven't been listening to but it
certainly applies to the main news
programs they are
it's a sieve they're aimed at an 8 year
old you know and the German and French
arraigned at at least a 16 year old okay
Nick what do you say says to be
defensive no just say it's in the
interests of these as it happens we took
the position on the Today programme that
our lead slot which is pretend as they'd
slot would be more often than not led by
an interview with the scientists and not
a minister to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit a I
dot TV for more debates and talks from
the world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas